SPEAKER 1: Here at
Whirlpool, we're
the largest manufacturer
of appliances in the world.
SPEAKER 2: Whirlpool has
been around almost 104 years.
It started right here in
Benton Harbor, Michigan.
We have 100,000
employees now worldwide.
SPEAKER 3: We're a very
relationship-based company.
We kind of have
small town values.
The center of everything
is the customer,
because that's where
our responsibility lies.
SPEAKER 1: Coming to
work at Whirlpool,
you get to work with
some really great people.
And you get to be a part of
products that are exciting.
Being able to execute
our business well
requires collaboration between
sales and merchandising teams,
between our manufacturing,
our product teams.
SPEAKER 2: The need
that we have to be
connected, the
speed with which we
need to operate have gone up.
SPEAKER 4: The opportunity
to make a global company
feel local, entrepreneurial,
feel fast-paced,
that's a big challenge.
Google Apps helps us get there.
What we've really done is
create an opportunity for people
to collaborate truly on a
global basis, regardless
of location, time, and place.
And that makes a huge
difference in terms
of the speed at
which we can operate.
SPEAKER 1: We're
tracking our metrics
all in one place
for the entire team.
We're looking at
it and saying, how
are we going to be able to
deliver our products when
our customers need it.
SPEAKER 4: The tools
really do create
that kind of
empowerment, to turn
people loose to be creative
and be their best self at work.
SPEAKER 1: We're really
creating products
that can make families'
lives a little bit better
in a behind-the-scenes
kind of way.
When we think
about our customer,
we try to think about
the way that they
would want to spend
their lives, and how
we can make that better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]